[Музика] [Музика] коли ти передчасно окуриваєш список просування, а не просто достатньо поточний чарт Ісса м'ясник, він знає, що спостерігач, тому привіт мене звуть Наталія, і я ваш учитель англійської мови, давайте почнемо сьогодні, ми запрошуємо наших гостей на наш урок англійської мови
Ірина Біллік, я дуже рада вас бачити тут привіт, привіт, як у вас все добре, дякую, чудово, так що давайте, я сподіваюся, що сьогодні ми всі щасливі та здорові так, подивіться на цю картинку, ці діти дуже щасливі та здорові, і давайте подумаємо про
що нам потрібно, щоб бути здоровими, що нам потрібно, щоб бути здоровими, давайте подумаємо про це незабаром важливо ні черевики попой не хвилюються на мені дратівливий син відмінний син так, коли світить сонце блакитне небо блакитне небо так у нас блакитне небо у нас є сонце і нам потрібно рухатися
для спорту відмінно так, нам потрібна підтримка, і нам потрібна хороша їжа або здорова їжа, тому ці дві речі будуть нашими темами спорт смачна їжа, тому давайте почнемо сьогодні з s PRT давайте почнемо зі спорту, тому я впевнений, що ви знаєте багато англійських слів
а
bout sport, тому що ці слова походять
з англійської, наприклад sport вам не
потрібно перекладати це sport або
давайте подивимося на це що це за
футбол футбол відмінно ви говорите
англійською дуже добре так футбол у нас є
їжа і ми маємо м'яч так легко ми
є цей вид спорту він дуже популярний
в усьому світі і в Україні подивіться
на картинку що це я чую
хлопці та дівчата що це за
плавання да плавання всім подобається
плавати ми плаваємо влітку тому що
плавання це літній вид спорту так так добре далі
що це  що це хто знає, дякую
китайський так ви маєте рацію,
ви бачите теніс теніс це також літній
вид спорту далі що це все
це знають що це карате карате це
бойове мистецтво фільм помилки бойове
мистецтво карате далі що це хто знає
так сноуборд сноуборд сноуборд ми йдемо
сноуборд взимку, тому що це
зимовий вид спорту далі що це за баскетбол
так відмінний баскетбол у
нас є кошик і у нас є м'яч ми
повинні покласти м'яч у ба  sket і у нас є
баскетбол це дуже популярний у
Сполучених Штатах далі що це хто знає, що
це катання на лижах це також зимовий
вид спорту це їзда на велосипеді їзда на велосипеді повторюйте
за мною
їзда на велосипеді подивіться на це слово їзда на велосипеді ми
любимо їздити на велосипеді влітку це ти знаєш,
йога о боже так  Я люблю йогурт Я займаюся йогою
щодня йога йога далі це верхова
їзда верхова їзда що це
так твоя права кишеня
це хокей зимовий вид спорту що це
хто знає, що це також гра з м'ячем і
бас бас бум бас наступний інший
літній вид спорту вітер  серфінг
віндсерфінг нам потрібен вітер нам потрібне море і ми
обслуговуємо, але також ми можемо служити в Інтернеті
так далі що це за коробка або бокс
бокс дуже небезпечний я не люблю
бокс ладно це що це
катання на ковзанах або більше катання на ковзанах або
фігура  кататися на ковзанах, коли я був молодим, я
катався на ковзанах,
і що це за шахи, цей чоловік
грає в шахи, добре.
Ой, ще раз, це залізний пруток
XI аеробіка Мені подобається висока аеробіка, тому
що ти  o деякі вправи з музикою,
а тепер повторюйте за мною з ареною
йога їзда на велосипеді їзда на велосипеді
велоспорт шахи
катання на ковзанах катання на ковзанах хороший
сноуборд
сноуборд аеробіка курс
їзда на конях катання на
конях шахи катання на ковзанах катання на ковзанах катання на ковзанах на
велосипеді
o  а тепер зимові види спорту
сноуборд сноуборд
ковзани ковзани літній вид спорту верхова їзда
Райтон їзда на велосипеді певний
спорт у приміщенні шахи шахи аеробіка аеробіка та
йога та йога я дуже люблю йогу я роблю
це кожен день
добре дякую добре, а тепер подивимося,
що ми пам'ятаємо  подивіться на ці фотографії
та спробуйте назвати цей вид спорту, який я вам покажу,
а ви спробуйте назвати його добре, скажіть мені, що
це за йога йога так, ви маєте рацію
катання на ковзанах хут катання на ковзанах відмінні
шахи хороші їзди на велосипеді їзда на велосипеді добре Аарон I
robux сноубординг сніг  Інтернат і
катання на конях
добре, давайте пограємо в гру, дурний батько, я
люблю цю гру, і мої діти люблять її
люблять -  наприклад,
повторюйте за мною обидва фільми Toyota, якщо
я скажу правильно yoshua випадкова проблема фактична
чиста прибуток ви знаєте, якщо я скажу неправильно, ви
просто плескайте в долоні добре давайте спробуємо йога
йога катання на ковзанах катання на ковзанах хто
катається верхова їзда їзда на велосипеді відмінно
так плесніть у долоні їзда на велосипеді  їзда на велосипеді
аеробіка привіт аеробіка фігурне катання добре
сноуборд сноуборд йога йога
шахи добре ви бачите, що знаєте багато
слів і ви пам'ятаєте це зараз я
хочу розповісти вам про дуже дивний
вид спорту, наприклад, якщо ми візьмемо шахи і
додамо бокс, це буде шаховий бокс  цей
вид спорту існує, це справжній спортивний шаховий
бокс, це виглядає дуже дивно, але це
наступний спорт, наприклад, якщо ми візьмемо
велоспорт і додамо м'яч, у нас буде
велом'яч, щоб ви могли побачити, що
можете винайти або подумати про свій власний
вид спорту  просто поєднайте два види спорту разом, це
дуже смішно,
добре, йдіть далі. О, навіть ми можемо посадити нашу собаку
на дошку для серфінгу, і ми будемо займатися
серфінгом для собак, ви уявляєте, що це
дуже дивно, але смішно, ви бачите поганий  собака
наступна на дошці для серфінгу, тому зараз у нас
буде дуже важлива частина, тому що
це частина граматики, ми можемо займатися
спортом, ми можемо займатися спортом, і ми можемо
займатися спортом, яка різниця,
яка різниця,
слухайте мене уважно, добре
спочатку  пам'ятайте ми граємо в теніс граємо в
бейсбол граємо в баскетбол граємо в хокей
граємо у футбол і граємо в шахи чи
можете ви здогадатися, чому ми використовуємо гру з усіма
цими портами подумайте про це я допоможу вам
ми граємо з цим портом, тому що
це ігри з м'ячем переважно
з цим  м'яч запам'ятати його налаштувати, ніби
це маленький підказка
малинка pedes скринька akka ми граємо зі
спортом з луком добре запам'ятати далі
ми йдемо плавати ми займаємося віндсерфінгом або собакою
серфінгом ми ходимо кататися на ковзанах кататися на
сноуборді кататися на лижах і кататися на
конях хто помітив, чому ми використовуємо go  з
усіма цими портами я допоможу вам,
тому що так, ми маємо в кінці і в
усьому
помічати це плавання катання на ковзанах серфінг у
нас є Inc так, пам'ятайте це, ми можемо додати
цю кінцеву емоцію Madhubala it sa  ys
схожий на Китай до дієслова do G Слава плавати
плавати хлопчик двері Америка риба риба
або дошка якщо це номер кімчі
мохіт резюме буддійська хмара
дані Слава ми можемо ми можемо скласти власні
слова з цим закінченням
добре далі і що ми робимо ми робимо  характер
ми займаємося йогою ми займаємося аеробікою ці
порти не командні у нас немає
командира це не командний вид спорту це більше
індивідуальний вид спорту йога карате та
аеробіка більш індивідуальний, але бокс у
нас у переможця взяв лише тут
, пам'ятайте, що бокс буде використовувати
займайся боксом добре запам'ятай, я впевнений, що
тобі легко,
давайте потренуватися, тому що я впевнений,
що англійська мова - це спорт, тому що щоб
добре говорити англійською, потрібно
багато тренуватися або багато тренуватися, давайте
потренуємося в атаці так, Арас  Я читаю
речення так, є гепард Регіна,
ми позитивно граємо в гроші. Іди
, ти повинен ввести правильне слово
добре, давайте спробуємо я прокидаюся о 7 годині
щодня і ммм йогурт що ти
відчуваєш у doo doo відмінно добре  Я і я
займаємося йогою номер два, давайте
плавати, коли закінчиться період ізоляції.
Калуза Кінч, це карантин,
давайте йти чудово, давайте йти плавати
наступні справи віндсерфінг минулого літа в
Єгипті так, вони
грали, грати ні, ні, ідуть, добре,
вони пішли  віндсерфінг минулого літа
добре номер чотири мій брат
не грає в шахи не грає в шахи так він
думає, що він думає, що це нудно з огляду на Дюма
це дуель просто диван Nautica оголена Нара
грає в шахи номер п'ять, коли настає зима,
я зазвичай ммм катаюся на ковзанах з  мої
друзі на Paju іду відмінно
я зазвичай катаюся на ковзанах номер шість я
думаю, що він вміє ммм бокс дуже добре робить
відмінну хорошу пам'ять у вас є
так, займайтеся боксом сім не ммм хокей
без шолома найкраще шоу лама це
небезпечно підкорити ламу безодні тепер
дон  Я не розумію, добре, добре,
це командна гра з шайбою, сором'язливий
ba-da-da mojo McGrath, це я, хм, ми можемо
грати з м'ячем або чимось іншим, не
граємо в хокей без шолома, добре, все
добре,
і зараз
вісім оцінок не катався на сноуборді на
зимових святах ішов не йшов він
катався на лижах, тому що це минулий скажи
удар Манорама він катався на лижах дуже добре
відмінно дуже добре Сподіваюся, ви це
запам'ятаєте, і у нас є ще трохи
часу  і я хотів би запропонувати вам
створити свою власну гру свою власну гру так,
що стосується ніяких вітамінів ми мали цю
владу через вас останній місяць ми
рух повторювався спокусник Пруст
абрикос ми рух схопимо м'яч
і я не  Знайте, можливо, ми можемо використати цю
коробку та пограти в паперовий м’яч, якщо ви хочете
спробувати взяти його та бінго так,
вітаємо, ви бачите, ви можете створити
свою власну гру, тому сьогодні на нашому уроці ми
згадали багато видів зимових видів спорту,
як-от катання на сноуборді чи ковзанах влітку
такі види спорту, як плавання або їзда на конях,
спорт у приміщенні, перед місією ADA,
сер спорт у приміщенні спорт на відкритому повітрі спорт
ключовий роман з ee, і навіть ми знайшли
деякі дивні види спорту, як-от шаховий бокс або
велом'яч, так, або собаки, які займаються серфінгом, собачий спорт
серфінг, і ми створили навіть нашу власну гру,
яка може називати
я не знаю паперова кулька О,
паперова кулька для сміття, так, і в кінці я
хотів би поставити вам
кілька запитань або дати вам кілька завдань, які
ви повинні дізнатися, скажи мені правду  або
неправда, сер Правда брехлива балаканина без
проблем, я скажу вам речення, і
ви відповісте мені, правда чи неправда,
наприклад, лижі - це зимовий вид спорту,
правда чи неправда, але
я не чую вас, хлопці та дівчата
зимовий вид спорту добре, давайте спробуємо ще раз, що ми
повинні робити, щоб бути здоровими. Відповідь їсти
гамбургери та дивитися телевізор,
правда чи неправда О, дурні, чудово, що
нам потрібно, щоб бути здоровими, нам потрібно займатися
спортом і добре харчуватися здоровою їжею.
не може служити
з нашим домашнім собакою ми не можемо служити з
нашим домашнім собакою вірно чи невірно хибно
відмінно ми побачили, що можемо ми можемо
служити з собакою, і це називає собачий серфінг
відмінним і, як останній,
грати в хокей без шолома небезпечно
не  небезпечно,
правда чи неправда, так, відмінно, добре
зроблено, ваша гра – правильна відповідь.
Щиро дякую, і я хотів би
, щоб ви спочатку зробили кілька завдань вдома,
а потім
знайшли дивні або незвичайні види спорту, як-от
шаховий бокс або серфінг для собак.
створіть свою власну гру і, можливо, намалюйте,
зробіть малюнок чи відео та надішліть нам,
а третій make Я дам вам деякі
вправи, але не фізичні вправи
вправи англійської мови, і ви попрактикуєтеся в
нашій граматиці go or do дякую,
і я сподіваюся  що ти любиш ці
уроки і ти пам'ятаєш багато нових
слів англійською дякую і до побачення
[Музика]
Yahoo - пуджа жадібне ставлення
прогулянки з моїм новим хворим, але ти отримуєш
вологу не вона зробила Будда, що
Вален запрягає синій  -фішка Домінік
наша Жюстін була особлива течія
знаю Майстри відповідають на поштовий
містичний я б не мав прибутку
[Музика]
тобі